this propaganda machine portrayed him as
a strong fearless leader who rules
russia with an iron fist but recent
images of president putin paint a rather
different picture a despotic dictator
with a bloated face and reports he's
riddled with cancer and parkinson's
disease well here's putin meeting the
president of belarus alexander
lukashenko in february hands trembling
feet shaking and here he is struggling
to walk at russia's victory day
celebrations earlier this month
well the former head of the british
secret intelligence service sir richard
dearlove joins me now richard great to
see you
you are the real life m aren't you well
you were i was once
c c not m c you were c i'm so sorry of
course you were you were higher up the
chain a perfect person then to talk
about what is going on with ukraine
because a lot of people thinking
the way to stop this is to get to putin
in your previous life
would you have
been contemplating using a james bond
like assassin to go in and take him out
i don't think that would have been a
practical approach to the problem so no
we did not it's a serious question well
it's a serious question i have muted the
idea of assassinating him as being the
way to stop what is going on do you
think it would even if we're not we're
not in the state of war with russia at
the moment so that would not in my view
be an option which the government could
even consider but your your belief is
that putin is sick and may not have long
to lift
uh
yeah my belief well take one look at him
if it was your father what would you
think yeah he was seriously ill i mean
i mean the fact that he shook hands at
that uh victory prayed with the with the
hand he doesn't use i think is a clear
indication that there's something
fundamentally wrong i mean let alone the
other symptoms that he's showing is it
more dangerous for the world
if he is say terminally ill with a
cancer or something and only he knows
this and his medical team is that more
dangerous because it may encourage him
to do something reckless
well i think if he's seriously ill his
judgment may be impaired
so you have a collision as it were
between the geopolitics of russia
and its loss of ukraine and putin's
health i think that's a pretty uh
unsavory combination of factors
it's a very unsettling time at the
moment for geopolitics you've got
president biden being quite forceful
about taiwan and what he may do taking
the american position to a slightly
stronger place than it's been before
saying he would engage militarily we've
obviously got ukraine you've got all the
issues with wheat and other produce now
potentially causing starvation
especially in africa middle east these
are worrying times you know massive
inflation
what do you make of it all you've been
around the block if you don't mind me
saying for a few decades have you seen
anything quite like this
no probably not we're living in a period
of you know geopolitical well maybe we
could we should call it crisis
uh
the pandemic's been probably the most
disruptive event socially and to an
extent politically since world war ii
and on top of that now
we have a major war on the european
continent so
and let alone the other problems with
you know the price of energy the
situation with china we have a
concatenation
of crises some larger than others but
yes it's highly problematic
does social media amplify all this in
the sense that when you were running mi6
you deal dealt with all sorts of massive
issues are things actually worse now are
they are they just amplified by the fact
that social media definitely exaggerates
and amplifies the problem and let's say
increases the level of social anxiety
because the messages of broadcast so
widely into so many people but i mean i
think the situation is genuinely
worrying and difficult and you know we
have a variety of apparently insoluble
and difficult problems facing the
government facing any government facing
any nation state
what's the thing you meet miss
most about being
c in mi6 running our spies and what's
the thing you you misleased
well i think
being in a position where you know a lot
about what's going on
uh i i guess i could say
i never really had a boring day at work
in my life
not many people could say that
uh it's a privilege to be
at the center yeah and to know what's
going on also slightly terrifying though
i mean well
the job is not for somebody who's of a
nervous disposition let's put it like
that i think you need to be relatively
calm in the way that you view crises
which at any moment can sort of escalate
in front of you what do what am i
pleased about well i think in a way i'm
pleased i'm not
head of the service any longer and i was
in it for a very long time
and i think i did my bit and served my
country
uh i'm very proud of that
but what was the moment if i could let
you relive it again what was the single
most memorable moment for whatever
reason of your tenure
oh i guess you it has to be 9 11 yeah
and the events of 9 11. and when that
happened i mean when you're in that job
you must know this is now your world has
completely changed so many did but were
you able to stay calm even in a moment
like that i think so
asked my colleagues and friends
i think i had a reputation for remaining
calm you also had a reputation for
integrity
if you had been caught as the boss of
mi6 during a pandemic with severe
lockdowns
hosting leaving parties
having a large number of your staff 86
of them getting fines from the police
for having a legal lockdown breaking
parties would you have fallen on your
sword and done the honorable thing i
wouldn't have been
in that position right so what do you
make of the fact that the prime minister
was in that position uh i think i'm
gonna avoid comment on the president you
don't have to sit on the fence anymore
so richard well on that particular issue
i i'm going to sit on the fence but i
mean what what i would say is that you
know if if if you're in an organization
particularly if you're leading an
organization like the secret
intelligence service the issue of
integrity is absolutely crucial
and so you wouldn't have put yourself in
that position i mean there's a picture
coming out tonight from pima carrera
from the daily mirror and it's a picture
of what is quite clearly a lavish amount
of alcohol for a party i mean there's
just no denying it do you think when we
get told as a public that's not a party
we're being taken from mugs so rich
all i would say is if you're a lawyer
it's quite difficult yes describe what
thank you what a party is
so i think that that's my reply to that
difficult question final question for
you who should be the next james bond
after daniel craig
and should it ever ever be a woman
um i'm a traditionalist
and i think
it should be a man because that's the
way ian fleming conceived of the role
correct and uh so
who would you like to see do it nick
well i've i've looked at the list of the
candidates and my pick
would be and i'm i'm not an expert no no
but if i was you are you actually you
are well
i'm an expert for the role yes um i
think the one who sits at best of the
list but i don't know all of them is
probably tom hiddleston really yeah
really yeah i think he ruined it with
the taylor swift
ocean t-shirt and you know more about
that than i do i'm an idris elba fan
myself i think he'd be a cracking well
he would be good i agree yeah but he's
got that sort of steely charm well you
need steely charm i did actually pitch
myself to barbara broccoli only three
months ago you would have been rather
well i saw the big leap from pierce
brosnan to piers morgan isn't it i must
be honest well maybe they should have
a real c as m yes why not a great idea
it's a written so why don't you suggest
it fantastic director so richard what a
pleasure nice to meet you very nice
thank you very much for joining me
you